ويقود فيديو هذه الساعة
حصريًا من قبل شبكة سي إن إن يظهر
القوات الروسية في شوارع بوشا بالقرب من
جثث مدنية
بعد أن كذب الكرملين إنكار أن القوات نفسها
كانت مسؤولة عن تلك
الفظائع.
لتبدأ بهذا
الفيديو الجديد الحصري من bucha ، ما الذي نتعلمه أكثر
عن هذا الفيديو ولماذا
يعد دليلًا مهمًا على ما حدث
في
bucha نعم جايك نريد أن نظهر لمشاهدينا
هذا الفيديو ولكن دعني أولاً أقول
إنه تصويري  أه بطبيعته لكن
من المهم أن نظهر
بسبب الدليل على ذلك أنك تعرف أنه
يظهر ما فعلته روسيا في bucha
وحقيقة أنه كما ذكرت
للتو الكرملين في الحقيقة لا يقول
الحقيقة هنا لذا ما يظهره هذا الفيديو من
المسيرة  في الثاني عشر والثالث عشر من آذار (مارس)
، تم تحديد موقع جغرافي
ومصادقته بواسطة CNN ، وهو يظهر عدة
أشياء مختلفة ولكنه يُظهر
المركبات المدرعة الروسية العسكرية الروسية
v  صور بالقرب من
جثث مدنية كانت في ذلك الشارع ،
يظهر مقطع فيديو آخر من 13 مارس
جنود روس بالقرب من جثث في تلك الشوارع ،
تلك الجثث هي نفس
الجثث التي عثرت عليها القوات الأوكرانية بعد ذلك عندما
استعادوا الضاحية في ضاحية كييف
في بوتشا في أبريل.  أولاً ، ضع في اعتبارك ما
يعنيه هذا أننا نعلم أن روسيا كانت
تسيطر على بوتشا يومي 12 و 13 مارس / آذار ،
نعلم أن هؤلاء الأشخاص
قُتلوا في بوتشا في
ذلك الوقت تقريبًا ونعلم أنه عندما
دخلت القوات الأوكرانية هناك ،
كانت تلك الجثث لا تزال على الأرض.  لذلك
عندما يقول الكرملين إنه ليس لديه علم
بارتكاب فظائع
وأن قواتهم لا علاقة لها
بها ، يتناقض هذا الفيديو بشكل مباشر مع هذا
البيان وهذا هو السبب في أن هذا الدليل
مهم للغاية ربما ليس من المستغرب
أن ترفض روسيا ووزارة دفاعها
نعترف بهذا
الجزء الأخير من الأدلة الحصرية من cnn
الأوكرانية السلطات اليوم
اعترفت بفقدان سيفيرا  البلدات الواقعة في الجزء الشرقي
من البلاد ، ما مدى أهمية
تلك الخسائر ،
نعم أعتقد أنه عندما تستمع إلى
ما يقوله الأوكرانيون إنهم
يعترفون بأنهم فقدوا هذه
البلدات ، لكن بالتأكيد ليس
معنى خسارة مدينة كبيرة مثل
ماريوبول  على سبيل المثال التي لم
تسقط أو هاركيف التي تتعرض باستمرار
للقصف الروسي في
ثانية ثاني أكبر مدينة أه في أوكرانيا
لكنها مهمة بمعنى
أنها تظهر تقدمًا تدريجيًا
من جانب الروس يتذكرون ما يتذكره الروس
يحاول الجيش القيام
هنا بمحاولة الاستيلاء على الجزء الشرقي
من البلاد عن طريق الانتقال من
الجنوب لأعلى من الشمال لأسفل
ومن الشرق إلى الداخل يحاولون
الاستيلاء على تلك المنطقة بأكملها ومن خلال
الاستيلاء على هذه البلدات الثلاث.
هذا أقرب بكثير إلى القيام بذلك ليس فقط
ولكن أيضًا لتطويق القوات الأوكرانية
الموجودة في ذلك الجزء من البلاد
والتي قالت دعونا لا نبالغ في تقدير ما يعنيه هذا
ساعدوا
أنهم نجحوا في صد حوالي تسعة
هجمات روسية مختلفة في
منطقتي دونيتسك ولوهان وحدهما
مؤخرًا قالوا إنهم استمروا في
إخراج الكثير من المعدات العسكرية الروسية
في هذه العملية ، لذا فهذه خسارة
للأوكرانيين لكنك لكنك
يقولون أيضًا إن خطوطهم الأمامية
تحتفظ إلى حد كبير بأنهارًا غير ثابتة
تقدم تقارير حية لنا من keeve ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك